hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the ethical writings that we still
possess by Epicurus we see one of the
main themes being echoed over and over
again that there are certain things that
human beings do tend to fear that it's
really not good or prudent for us to
fear and one of the things that he wants
to do with your philosophical argument
is to lead us away from these fears this
is one of the things that philosophy in
his view can actually provide to us so
when we think about fear what is fear in
this this epicurean perspective fear is
a mental disturbance it's it's a feeling
it's a passion and as a passion that
causes us some pain or some grief it
disturbs us it keeps us from being
tranquil we're never quite at home with
ourselves when we're fearing we can't
enjoy the things that we actually have
when work when we're inhabited by fear
sometimes we actually do turn to
pleasures to try to mask fear or to
distract ourselves from fear but
Epicurus like I put here he thinks that
fear is actually worse than physical
pains and so it's mental pains and
pleasures have a predominance over
physical pains and pleasures for him the
attempts to try to compensate by
indulging ourselves and pleasures not
really going to address our fear so how
can we really address our fears how can
we become free of them well we have to
first of all be conscious of what we're
actually afraid of and in his time he
identified two things in particular or
two sets of things in particular one of
them is an odd thing according to him
that people tended to focus on one of
them is the gods or fate or the workings
of the universe and the natural world
and the other is death
now how applicable is this to our own
time well you know we're all going to
die the mortality rate for human beings
at least in a physical sense is a
hundred percent in any given population
right sooner or later all physical life
ceases there are people who are you know
working on this anti-death you know sort
of idea but but that's at this point
just sort of science fiction we are not
in world as a matter of fact even the
gods are not necessarily immortal from
an epicurean point of view there they're
just different kinds of beings what
about the gods or fate do we still have
concerns about that sort of thing where
are many religious believers they are
not you know practicing for the most
part the same religion that Epicurus was
had in mind the polytheistic common
persons view on the gods as a matter of
fact Epicurus says those people are they
think they're pious but they're actually
impious because they don't know the true
nature of the gods and they by you know
they do all these prayers and have all
these fears about the gods there are a
lot of people who whether we you know
change it and make it a monotheistic
thing have something identifiable with
what what he's talking about and there
are other people who tend to view the
universe as a necessarily hostile place
inhabited by you know some sort of you
know meanness towards human beings or
indifference towards human beings
there are some people who believe in a
kind of determinism that we cannot
escape from
so Epicurus it is you know addressing
these sorts of concerns let's look first
in his his views on the gods and this is
the views not only about the curious but
of all of his school that's going to
follow him first of all
against some of the other philosophical
schools of antiquity Epicurus asserted
that there actually is human freedom
that maybe some things follow by natural
processes and causal orders as a matter
of fact he had a whole you know sort of
atomic theory that that fits in with
this but there's also the possibility of
freedom and we experience this so we
don't have to be concerned that our
destiny has been cast in stone and we
can't escape it we are to some degree
responsible for ourselves we can choose
which path we go on we have some control
over our own lives what about the gods
Epicurus didn't believe in the gods he
says most people have got them wrong the
gods are these perfectly blissful higher
beings and because they're perfectly
blissful they have nothing to do with
human beings or human affairs
they don't take an interest they don't
you know play favorites they don't get
involved in our Wars like I put here
gods don't get angry they don't become
envious the ancient Greeks you know
worried quite a bit about making the
gods envious if you get too successful
maybe the gods are gonna stick it to you
because they're they don't like it when
you're like the gods
Epicurus says no look there were totally
blissful beings they enjoy a higher
state of existence than us and if they
actually did get involved with us
there's two things that we could say one
is they no longer enjoyed the kind of
happiness that they do enjoy right
because they'd be bound up with all of
our craziness down here but the other
thing is to be able to get angry to be
upset about things is in Epicurus view a
sign of a kind of imperfection a
weakness
the part and so if we if we think of the
gods as being these maximal beings they
wouldn't have that as part of what they
are so what this means for us is not
only are we free but the gods aren't
going to mess around with us and
interfere with us as a matter of fact we
can look at the gods as being sort of
examples of what we should aspire to
natural phenomena the Greeks were and
the Romans were very concerned as many
people were about the connection between
natural phenomena and the will of God or
the gods
Epicurus ins they have nothing to do
with each other earthquakes happen for
natural causes hail storms happen and
destroy crops by natural causes we can
actually do natural science or what he
called physics at the time and we can
make sense of this if you get sick it's
because some disease organism as we now
say all right there's a lot been a lot
of theories of medicine about what
causes disease like the asthma and
things like that but you know if you get
cancer according to Epicurus it's not
because god has it in for you or god is
trying to punish you or you did
something wrong and guys punishing if
it's natural causes and we have the
freedom to study these things and to
make sense of them and if we do go on
and study these things a lot of
epicurean philosophy was indeed about
trying to make sense of meteorological
phenomena we will enjoy life more
because we will understand the universe
that will become intelligible to us it
will no longer be a source of fear but
rather a source of confidence and even
pleasure what about this though dad we
can't avoid death as a matter of fact
Epicurus says everybody who comes in
this world is moral and there's no way
around that so you know don't live as if
you're going to live forever live in a
prudent way so that you can actually get
the most out of this life he also thinks
this is going to be talked about a
little bit later in a different video
that the old person who is close to
death can
in fact have the most pleasant life
because they have this entire stock of
memories that they can look back on
death puts a limit to that though but
what is death according to Epicurus
death is simply the cessation of
sensation we no longer sense anything we
no longer perceive and indeed of
existence there it's not as if I lose my
existence as if existence was a property
according to Epicurus there's no longer
any me to lose anything there
there's no immortal soul there's no you
know mind that lasts beyond the body for
Epicurus this is what you get what you
see is what you get literally for him
right so this actually introduces a kind
of dilemma to us but it's a happy
dilemma
according to Epicurus when can we
actually be afraid of death we can be
afraid of death as something coming in
the future which then we would fear when
we're alive and Epicurus says it's
really silly for you to be fearing death
then because it ain't here Yeah right if
you're if death is in the future why are
you concerned about something that is
happening down the line but it's not yet
present so while we're living we don't
need to fear death because we are living
what about when we hit that point
well it's no longer a point for us when
we hit it because there's no us there's
no there's nothing beyond that for the
being that is experiencing death as a
matter of fact you cannot according to
Epicurus experience your death or suffer
death because when you die when death
comes that's the end of that person the
person no longer has existence that is
what it means so if you shouldn't fear
death right now because there's nothing
to actually fear because it's far off
and you shouldn't fear death because
when it happens there won't be a you to
actually suffer it the the conclusion of
that is that it's a groundless fear from
ourselves of death now why might
somebody actually be afraid
you know they could be concerned about
their legacy
they could be concerned about the people
that they're leaving behind they could
be concerned about you know the house
that they're abandoning they could also
be worried about an afterlife in which
the gods are going to punish them for
being such jerks or the gods will punish
them because they're jerks are something
along those lines but Epicurus has
already cut off that possibility and if
we have our our way of living straight
there's not going to be anything that we
need to worry about after we die
interestingly Epicurus one of the things
that we do have preserved from him in
Diogenes leontes is his last will and
testament he actually did leave a legacy
he established that philosophical school
the garden and he laid down provisions
for how it ought to run including the
celebration of his birthday which was
you know celebrated the way that many
people will celebrate you know religious
figures birthdays as well right but you
know what is he ultimately concerned
about that would he allow himself to get
upset if he thought or feared that
things might not come to pass the way
that he ordained them no those things
are not in his control and even if they
they didn't go that way there's no
Epicurus left anymore to be bothered by
it it's not like there's Hades where you
can be looking up and say oh look at
what they did with the lawn you know
that's not going to happen in that case
so Epicurus thinks that if we can
eliminate these groundless fears we will
in fact have opened up the the path to
happiness for ourselves